hi there and welcome to the third video
in our series on SRE
and devops my name is Seth and I'm a
developer advocate at Google focused on
infrastructure and operations and I'm
Liz and essary focused on teaching
Google cloud customers how to build and
operate reliable services in the
previous video we discussed the
differences between SL is SL OS and SLA
s SL is our quantitative measurements
like latency SLO s are the amount of
time that an SLI can be out of
specification an SLA s our business
agreements with explicit consequences
for failing to deliver service
well what stops teams from breaking
their agreed-upon SLO s and forcing sres
to work overtime it seems like a classic
DevOps problem where product teams want
to ship new features but SR E's need to
maintain a reliability is there anything
in the SOE program that can help with
this classic problem that's what we use
error budgets for error budgets well
before we talk about error budgets let's
talk about risk and availability as I
mentioned in the previous episode trying
to go for a hundred percent availability
just isn't a good idea because it's
expensive it's technically complex and a
lot of cases it winds up being the case
that users don't even see the benefits
of it because of unreliability somewhere
else in the system I see that makes a
lot of sense because if my cellular
network is only 99 percent reliable but
my service is 99.9% reliable my users
are never going to experience that
additional point nine percent of
reliability because their cellular
network is likely to fail before my
service does yes that's exactly correct
so while we want to reduce the risk of
system failures we have to accept some
degree of risk in order to deliver these
products and features but how do we
determine how much risk of service is
willing to tolerate so that's a product
decision so we have to work with the
product management team to figure out
what is our explicit goal for the
availability target of our service and
there are many things to think about
like how much is it going to cost to add
extra fault tolerance or to add extra
testing time or to reduce our frequency
of pushes or to increase how long it
takes for us to decide that a release is
good compared to the benefits to the
user of increase
reliability I see so the acceptable risk
of a system dictates the SLO and the SLO
mathematically defines the error budget
if the service incurs too much downtime
we have to reduce the risk to remain
within the SLO which might mean halting
deployments if service owners want to
deliver a lot of risky features they
have to be willing to accept a much
looser SLO because if they were to
choose a strict SLO they would quickly
exceed their error budget which could
halt future deployments exactly so the
main benefit of an error budget is that
it's a quantitative measurement that's
shared between the product and essary
teams which means that we can balance
innovation and stability to an
appropriate level so as long as the S
all those are met releases can continue
but how do we know if an SLO breach is
about to occur so when we defined
earlier the expectation of how much
optimist service was going to have and
how we're going to measure it well we
need to actually concretely implement
that using a neutral third party like a
monitoring system well and the metrics
from that monitoring system those are
the slis right exactly and the
difference between the actual uptime and
the calculated target up time from our
SLO is the budget of how much
unavailability that we can tolerate for
the system to be stable over the entire
window of the SLO so we call this the
error budget if your SOS are failing all
the time then you're going to be burning
through your error budget and then
eventually you need to stop your future
releases in order to focus instead on
making reliability improvements and
restructuring your application so that
it can meet your s ELO's in the future
so who enforces those policies though
cuz couldn't a product team just go over
and break the SLO and force the S or YZ
to work overtime so this is why we need
to have executive buy-in for error
budgets if the s3 teams don't have the
ability to enforce their budgets then
the whole system is going to break down
so some teams just allow for a limited
number of tokens or golden bullets that
you can hand out to a vice-president for
example so if a product team really
wants to get that critical feature out
well they're going to have to ask the
vice president for a one-time exception
and they'll only get a certain number
per year I see but what about things
that are like outside of the product
team that aren't necessarily buggy code
for my developers like someone cuts an
undersea cable or there's a catastrophic
failure at a data center those shouldn't
impact my error budget it wasn't my
fault so this is why it's important to
have error budgets from top to bottom
for everything in your stack that way
you can figure out how much error budget
you allocate to your dependencies and
how much error budget is reserved for
your developers to spend and this is
another reason why targeting a hundred
percent availability isn't realistic
because all of your dependencies are not
a hundred percent available either that
makes a lot of sense but what about
other things like restarting a failed
service or other kind of manual tasks
are those considered part of the error
budget yeah so Seth when you have to do
manual action to keep your system from
failing in the weight before you
actually do that manual option you'll
start burning through your error budget
right but their actual act of doing that
manual work we track that separately and
that's a concept that we call toil so
we'll talk about that more in detail in
the next video
great so risk and error budgets are
directly related to many of the DevOps
principles that we've discussed in
earlier episodes it clearly defines that
accidents are normal by quantifying
accidents and risk through error budgets
it also enforces that change should be
gradual because a non gradual change
could quickly burn through the error
budget for a particular product breaking
the SLO and preventing further
deployment for the quarter or for the
year this has really helped a lot I
think it's really clear why we say that
class sre implements DevOps thanks
everyone for watching check the
description below for links and more
information don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and stay tuned for our next
video where we talk about toil budgets